بقره فريضه لافته للانظار وصل صداها انحاء
العالم وتوافد اليها الالاف من السكان
لمشاهدتها عن قربه واقتناص صوره بالقرب
منها
انها البقره تراني اقصر بقره في العالم
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
[موسيقى]
في بنغلاديش وتحديدا في هذه المزرعه
بمدينه شاري غرام على بعد 30 كيلومترا
جنوب غرب العاصمه دكا كانت هذه البقره
حديث الملايين من سكان بنغلاديش ونجمه على
اوراق الصحف المحليه وفي برامج القنوات
التلفزيونيه
راني بعمرها الذي بلغ عامين وصل ارتفاعها
الى 51 سم فقط وطولها لسته وستين سنتيمترا
ووزنها لسته وعشرين كيلو جرام
وبمفردها تمكنت هذه البقره القزمه من
تحويل قريتها الى منطقه جذب سياحي
[موسيقى]
في عام 2021 وفي ظل تفشي كبير لفيروس
كورونا في بنجلاديش ورغم توقف وسائل النقل
حينها في جميع انحاء البلاد جميع هذه
الاجراءات لم ترضع السكان عن رؤيه رانيا
استقلوا عربات تقليديه صغيره وقطعوا
مسافات طويله ليفوز بصوره بجوار رانيا
لدرجه انه زارها 15 الف شخص خلال ثلاثه
ايام فقط
باللغه المحليه فقره من الفصيله البوتانيه
وتشتهر بلحومها الشهيه في بنغلاديش ويبلغ
الحجم الطبيعي للابقار من سلالتها ضعف
حجمها
دخلت راني في صراع على لقب الاقصر مع بقره
تدعى من سلاله فيشور وهي بقره في ولايه
كيرال الهنديه بلغ ارتفاعها واحد وستين
سنتيمترا وكانت تحمل الرقم القياسي
العالمي لكن راني تفوقت عليها
عروض البيع انهالت على ملاك وعرض عليهم
مبلغ مليون اي حوالي عشره الاف دولار لكن
نظرا لانهم تقدموا بطلب للحصول على رقم
قياسي عالمي ورفضت جميع العروض
حصلت راني اخيرا على شهاده من موسوعه
بكونها الاقصر في العالم لكنها فارقت
الحياه جراء اضطرابات في المعده قبل ان
تشاهد بعينيها لحظه تنصيبها باللقب
العالمي
[موسيقى]